[Musica]
chi ti puoi riconoscere le artiste in
questa immagine da una parte john
sebastian bach compositore e musicista
tedesco del periodo barocco
le sue opere sono state composte per la
maggior parte nella prima metà del
settecento tra questi ci sono i concerti
brandeburghesi o la famosissima toccata
e fuga era minore
dall'altra parte lo avete già
riconosciuto bob dylan cantautore
americano artista poliedrico tuttora
attivo e padre di alcuni dei più grandi
successi della musica leggera
tra questi ci sono blowin in the wind o
like a rolling stone
cosa unisce questi due artisti che
all'apparenza sono così diversi tra di
loro
il legame segreto è che entrambi sono
due grandi testimoni della relazione tra
la musica e la matematica johann
sebastian bach scrisse la maggior parte
delle sue opere con l'unico intento di
fare una speculazione teorico matematica
tra queste troviamo le sue geometrie
musicali su cui si fondano i canoni di
bach facendovi un esempio il movimento
contrario un rovesciamento e uno di
questi in cui gli intervalli ascendenti
iscritti presenti nella prima parte del
brano sono poi riflessi nei intervalli
discendenti della seconda parte del
brano bob dylan
da parte sua non ha mai negato
importante il ruolo della matematica
nelle sue opere e neanche nelle sue
interviste
nel 1965 infatti ci ha dichiarato io
sono un cantante matematico uso le
parole come la maggior parte delle
persone utilizzano i numeri e ancora
anno successivo ritorna sull'argomento e
dice non sono un canto di protesta ma
canto ordinarie canzoni matematiche si
tratta di addizionare sottrarre dividere
e moltiplicare il legame tra la musica e
la matematica in realtà
va hanno origine ancora più storiche nel
sesto secolo avanti cristo in cui
pitagora fa i primi esperimenti e ci dà
ci regala quella che poi è diventata la
scala pitagorica scala non fa altro che
dimostrare in maniera empirica una
relazione tra la lunghezza di una corda
e l'altezza della nota che viene suonata
su quella corda per esempio se prendiamo
una corda e la andiamo a pizzicare
troviamo una nota ma andando a tagliare
a metà quella corda
troviamo poi una nota che ha una
relazione di un'ottava rispetto a quella
precedente
se andiamo a tagliarla in tre parti
troviamo una relazione di una quinta in
quattro parti le relazioni di una quarta
è così che è pitagora ci dimostra che
c'è una vera e propria relazione tra la
distanza numerica tra la stanza
matematica e la distanza armonica della
comune scala musicale che noi conosciamo
con sette note
tantissimi artisti dal sesto secolo
avanti cristo in avanti hanno continuato
a sperimentare ea parlare di questa
relazione
e non è un caso da parte mia mi sono
fermata più volte nella mia vita a
riflettere su questa relazione prima
come appassionata di musica poi come
musicista e infine come persona che
lavora all'interno dell'industria
musicale fin da piccola
all'età di due anni ho nemmeno mi
ricordano le foto
amavo sara nella mia camera e ascoltare
i vinili che probabilmente in quel
periodo
suonavano la musica musiche dei bambini
i primi anni 80
all'età di sei anni guardando i primi
concerti in televisione sono stata
folgorata dal suono del violino e ho
chiesto alla mia famiglia di poter
studiare la musica proprio imparando
questo strumento e utilizzandolo come
modo per collegarmi a questo mondo da
quel momento in avanti fino all'età di
21 anni quindi per 15 anni ha proseguito
i miei sogni di violino ma anche di
musica dando per esempio all'età di 11
anni il primo esame di teoria e
solfeggio in
conservatorio e proprio durante quel
periodo in quell'età cominciavano a
formarsi anche i miei gusti musicali
mi ricordo la grande emozione nel
ricevere in regalo i primi album che
ovviamente poi appunto hanno proprio ha
costruito i miei gusti musicali
tra questi ci sono bad di michael
jackson like a prayer di madonna
disintegration e the cure o ancora music
for the masses dei depeche mode
io sono sicura che chi di voi tra il
pubblico è un mio coetaneo proverà la
stessa emozione di nostalgia guardando
queste copertine tuttora a trent'anni di
distanza
ricordo ancora a memoria le parole di
ogni singolo brano di questi album e
questo perché il modo in cui approcciamo
l'ascolto andava a guardare a studiare
sia la musica che le parole non
prevedeva un processo diverso
fintanto che non andavo a memorizzare e
quindi ad ascoltare a rotazione tutte le
canzoni non ero contenta e non mi
ritenevo soddisfatta avevo ancora della
scoperta da fare ma solamente a
vent'anni ho avuto un'illuminazione e
sono riuscita a dare una risposta a
quello che era mio approccio all'ascolto
della musica e questa risposta alla
avuta dalla lettura di un libro
questo libro si chiama 31 canzoni di
ricordi e nick horby in questo libro in
questo saggio ci racconta come molte
persone approcciano l'ascolto delle
canzoni in maniera continuativa andando
ad ascoltare all'infinito quasi con
l'intento di andare a lisa risolverle
come se fossero dice delle pozze di
matematiche ed improvvisamente questo
concetto ha avuto in senso incredibile
nella mia mente mi ha dato una
spiegazione rispetto a tutto il tempo
che avevo passato ad ascoltare e perché
andiamo a risolverle perché la nostra
mente ha necessità di andare a cercare
una serie di toni accordi note che in
qualche modo ci creano quei meccanismi
neuronali che creano il piacere
dell'ascolto
ma toni accordi e note non sono anche
quegli elementi e matematici e di cui si
parlava prima pitagora e allora tutto
torna come musicista e come persona che
ha studiato il violino
una delle cose che si imparano nelle
prime fasi e la capacità di saper
pizzicare una corda in un punto
specifico che ti da una relazione
univoca tra la nota che vuoi suonare e
la tonalità di quella nota e ti basta
davvero uno sbaglio millimetrico sulla
tastiera per riuscirò ad avere una nota
completamente sbagliata e questa è una
delle cose di cui pure più avevo paura
quando suonavo il palco a suonare il
violino perché in quel momento si
ottiene un risultato completamente
diverso un errore
esattamente come quando in un'equazione
matematica ci portiamo un calcolo di
decimale sbagliato e otteniamo un
risultato che è completamente diversa
negli anni abbandonato lo studio del
violino per proseguire con i miei studi
ma questo mi ha lasciato ampio spazio
poi di muovere i primi passi in quella
che sarebbe stata la mia carriera
professionale che voleva a tutti i costi
che fosse a contatto con la musica
dopo vent'anni e dopo aver fatto diverse
esperienze in varie città del mondo in
vari media o la grandissima fortuna di
essere ritornata a lavorare
nell'industria musicale quindi a
contatto della mia della mia prima
passione
nel frattempo però il mondo è
completamente cambiato rispetto ai tempi
in cui ascoltavo i vinili nella mia
camera siamo passati alle audiocassette
poi cd poi agli mp3 e poi di nuovo a
quello che chiamiamo il cloud tramite le
piattaforme digitali della musica in
questo momento con un solo clic ci
possiamo connettere a un intero catalogo
di brani milioni di brani che provengono
da tutto il mondo
ma allora adesso su cosa si basa la
sfida dell'ascolto come possiamo di
nuovo riconnetterci con quelle emozioni
che io provavo quando ero più piccola le
piattaforme di musica e lo sanno
perfettamente che la migliore esperienza
si basa sulle offrire un metodo di
ricerca e una personalizzazione
del servizio per ciascuno di noi e come
si fa ad ottenerlo di nuovo la parola ce
la dà la matematica
la risposta sta in un algoritmo fa in
una serie di analisi di dati che ci
possono ritornare la migliore esperienza
musicale parecchie di queste piatti
tutte le piattaforme musicali danno a
disposizione una serie di playlist
players di genere playlist in base
all'umore in base a quello che stiamo
facendo se stiamo cucinando stiamo
facendo sport e queste splaylist si
basano proprio su una serie di dati di
ascolto dei nostri interessi ma anche
rispetto alla musica che condividiamo un
like mi piace che mettiamo su una
canzone che abbiamo appena ascoltato e
proprio grazie all'analisi dei dati le
piattaforme riescono a fornire la
miglior colonna sonora della nostra vita
in maniera giornata e dinamica in ogni
momento ma non solo grazie a questo
calcolo matematico siamo anche in grado
di anticipare i nostri gusti di andare a
creare quell elemento di novità in base
a quello che abbiamo ascoltato
precedentemente e quindi capiamo quanto
la personalizzazione sia importante
l'anno del covip ce lo ha dimostrato è
stato un anno molto difficile in cui
abbiamo passato più tempo in casa ad
ascoltare insieme alla nostra famiglia è
un trend che è emerso grazie all'analisi
dei questi dati che abbiamo ascoltato
più musica strumentale che in qualsiasi
altro periodo
questo perché questo genere di musica ci
permetteva di disconnetterci di
rilassarci di militare di staccarci
dalla realtà che tuttora è ancora molto
difficile da affrontare
mi sono soffermata appunto più volte a
pensare a questa relazione
ed è strano pensare come la musica che è
sinonimo di libertà creativa ed emozioni
sia una delle arti più vicini alla
matematica che è sinonimo di calcolo
di razionalità da una parte abbiamo
visto come è impossibile prescindere
dalla matematica per fare musica per
ascoltare musica per scrivere musica
proprio come se la musica fosse una meta
matematica una trasformazione della
matematica per attingere di nuovo dal
greco dall'altra parte
viviamo in una realtà in cui le nostre
scelte sono sempre più facilitate da
algoritmi da realtà virtuale da
intelligenza artificiale e io penso che
per la musica sia molto importante che
noi esseri umani con siamo noi a
disegnare questi questi algoritmi perché
la musica deve mantenere una continua
associazione con quello che di più
intangibile abbiamo la capacità unica di
essere noi umani di poterci emozionare
grazie mille